de nombreux enfants du pays du cèdre
pourrait ne jamais retourner sur les
bancs de l'école
dans un contexte de crise économique et
sanitaire avec des licenciements massifs
à la clé de nombreuses familles n'ont
plus les ressources suffisantes pour
scolariser leurs enfants
l' ong britannique save the children
tire la sonnette d'alarmé la pauvreté
représente un obstacle majeur à l'accès
des enfants à l'éducation
alors que de nombreuses familles ne
peuvent pas se payer du matériel
scolaire ou doivent compter sur les
enfants pour apporter un revenu selon
l'organisation
près de 1,2 million d'élèves ont déjà
quitté les salles de classe depuis
l'apparition de la pandémie
l'enseignement est devenu hors de portée
pour un bon nombre d'entre eux leurs
familles n'ayant pas les moyens
d'investir pour mettre en place des
cours à distance
cette crise touche l'ensemble des
couches sociales
plongé dans un marasme économique sans
précédent en deux ans la livre libanaise
a perdu 95% de sa valeur entraînant dans
son sillage une hausse drastique des
prix et une paupérisation généralisée
désormais un libanais sur deux vit au
dessous du seuil de pauvreté
le liban traverse actuellement une
réelle crise monétaire qui a conduit à
un effondrement financier l'argent de la
population a été volé
la banque centrale dispose de pouvoirs
qu'aucune autre banque centrale au monde
ne possède pointé du doigt pour son
inaction le pouvoir rencontres toutes
les peines du monde à former un
gouvernement depuis le départ de celui
d'hassan diab en août dernier après la
double explosion du port de beyrouth
difficultés sanitaires récession
économique est désormais catastrophe
scolaires annoncée depuis quelques temps
au liban une crise peut en cacher une
autre